hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
i saw this test for geniuses on puzzling
stack exchange and while i didn't figure
it out i thought it was a fun problem
in the following shapes which of the
following four shapes best fits where
the question mark is
give it a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the answer
in these types of problems there are
arguably many correct answers
but here's the solution that many people
thought was the best fit
the key is looking at each shape like a
jigsaw piece
you might start to see how the pieces
fit together
the second row is a little bit trickier
the pieces fit vertically
we can then put all of the pieces
together
so which piece is the best fit
we want this to fit at the very end
so let's take a look
we'll try each piece
and we only get one piece that's a
perfect fit
and that's our answer
shape b
thanks for watching
these videos available for free on
youtube build confidence for students
and inspire mathematical discovery for
viewers around the world they have over
150 million views and the channel has
over 1 million subscribers
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
you